the state department just yesterday
tweeted out its support of international
pronouns day
state department tweets out yesterday
quote today on international pronouns
day we share why so many people list
pronouns on their email and social media
profiles
read more here
that's great we we really support
pronouns and people and men pretending
to be women
right this is what it says actually
underneath
you can read it in the post read on to
learn why it matters what pronouns you
use to refer to people and how the
united states embraces sharing pronouns
so
there are two questions here or two
possibilities i guess to the question
why why is america sharing this
is it because america is just oblivious
to how radical this idea is that men can
be women and it's important to pretend
that men are women in some cases
or is it because the u.s state
department knows that this is a
poisonous but very effective ideology
and the united states is whipping it
weaponizing it to increase our power and
influence around the world
i don't know
i don't know
i suspect it's some combination actually
i suspect that most of the pawns who are
pushing this just think it's just true
it's just true that men can be women we
it's just good to do that and i suspect
a lot of people at the top recognize
that it's a powerful ideological weapon
it's an information weapon
either way though
it is authoritarian it is an imperial
ideology and people do have the right to
resist it
you know back when the united states
stood for truth justice in the american
way
back when we were a christian nation in
our self-understanding back when the
west broadly was christendom
i think a lot of us could get on board
with
sending that overseas i mean that's that
was the point of columbus's voyage that
was the point of western exploration
just to share the good news of the
gospel and the civilization that
christianity created to the rest of the
world
and we're on i'm on board with that yeah
let's do it let's go let's bring the
good news man let's do it as a great
civilization let's share it with people
but now if the empire is going abroad to
share
transgender bathrooms and climate
hysteria and fear of the sun monster
i'm not on board with that
and i have a great deal of empathy
actually for the nations in africa or
asia or wherever else that want to
resist it i'm so glad that you enjoyed
that clip i enjoyed it too i enjoyed
bringing it to you i'm glad that you
could listen and i could talk sometimes
people don't get the notifications
though that's a big problem the way to
fix that problem
ring the bell
subscribe
okay not just here hear me out
over at apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play aol instant messenger live
journal xanga
wherever man go subscribe to the michael
knowles show podcast leave a five-star
review if you wouldn't mind i'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you